yeah welcome to this video FM chromos i
played him a number of times already and
we got yeah something like that she goin
wow that's crazy for I have this line
now it's not really great but not that
easy to a field as well 95 should be
good it's a bit of an ardent but with
some differences there are the Knights
missing I even had this in a tournament
game once and was so quiet um yeah I
remember I wasn't exactly thrilled that
I didn't one this is really not a great
opening black needs to invest time to
even get the porn back it's not clear
that this is some at the end he'd even
nerd leading to a decent position okay
so should I just allow him to take it
yeah I mean insides not exactly helping
his development so III now is he 3 a
move attacking the pawn on d4 instantly
or Bishop f4 if I go Bishop f4 what does
he move he probably retreats the night
yeah okay yeah let's try to open up the
position this should be a good news
if he takes I will take on da dat take
III this has got his King in the middle
and I should have a good play that this
this is really what about before just
before I cannot take Queen a four wins
apiece yeah so thought so um okay and
the idea is what exactly if I take you
want to take on c4s maybe this but what
if i play c5 just c5 provoking him to
take on e3 now I can okay exchange here
okay yeah this should be really nice yes
but I can play Knight c3 here tending 90
45 and 90 for the question is has gotten
idea three check but i really want ya to
am do i need 95 pro bed
so I'm intending 94-95 harassing as
Bishop Knight B 5 is also booth so here
we go yeah probably should be 7i I doubt
Wow yeah okay this should be a really
excellent for wired with the two bishops
and a bad structure
I may be the instant f4 would have been
better even read it it's pretty pretty
awful as it is but
look at it and yes should I go t 1 is
the Bishop g4
yeah let's just drop it back
if he goes whoop dee three yeah Roxy one
I actually got rookie three what a what
a pained I thought Bishop b4 would would
win actually green Roxy one night
somewhere and then Bishop before I
thought this was winning already but
it's not his squad rookie three
yeah just to just play this it just it's
just excellent for white okay so now
just a three or is the Sun better move
try to keep it simple
how to improve activate a bit first
you want to expand even more with g4
yeah but this this gives him a weakness
on c6 Jack
why come to be seven also quite inviting
your black isn't exactly in sport with
active ideas you can just stay basically
check
yeah black cannot move much can do this
but yeah after five years so don't have
many moves Jack Bishop of 7 f-6 was my
idea with Bishop go through age six Jake
coming check check check
black resigns yeah I can just go King e7
then then move move the f porn should be
should be winning yeah I kept some
advantage throughout but not sure maybe
there was some some cleaner ways to do
it was always somewhat better here can
also consider to take and play for them
also good a 45 check check check check
yeah this is this is gone I don't know
pretty pretty good witness I guess I'm
always always awesome ahead in this game
not sure how much but it was looking ok
yeah thanks for watching